what's going on everybody welcome to
another Python tutorial series this
tutorial series is going to be covering
OpenCV with pythons so OpenCV is an
image processing library that has
bindings for Python Java and C so a lot
of the functionality and fundamentals
that you'll learn here pretty much
applicable across the board but most of
the programs that we're going to be
writing here are going to be Python so
first of all this is the opencv website
and we're in the downloads at the moment
if you have tried to follow any other
OpenCV tutorial you're going to probably
have them starting you off with
downloading open CV and building and
making all this kind of nonsense it's
not necessary you can do that if you
want but pretty much for a while you can
actually use the very much simplified
Python open CV so for that if you're on
Windows or Linux it's a little different
but you need a few things so let me pull
down the command prompt so this is
obviously Windows you're on Windows what
you're going to want to do is pip
install numpy and you're also going to
want matplotlib and then you're going to
want to get cv2 now at the time i
filling this pip install CV - it's going
to act like it worked but it didn't work
so keep that in mind pip install CV -
may work in the future go ahead and try
it and then when you're all done you can
run Python like c 5 python and then
import cv - and if that works
congratulations if it doesn't work sorry
you lose so on Windows you're going to
want to pip install numpy papist on
matplotlib and then you're going to need
open CV so the if you follow along my
tutorials very often you'll find that I
use this website a lot mainly because I
have 64-bit version of Python and it
causes trouble sometimes but forgetting
open CV you can come here search for
open CV found open CV come down here and
download the version that suits you if
you're looking for older versions you
can get these two down here but I've got
C Python so CP 3.5
and then amd64 64-bit so that's what I
would download if you're on a 32-bit
version of Python you would download
this version just because you're on
64-bit Windows does not mean your Python
installation is 64 the default is 32 so
keep that in mind so you download that
and install via pip install if you don't
know how to do that I do have a pip
install tutorial here go to python
program net you can go to the basics and
find it there here we can go start
learning basic search for pip there it
is there's a tutorial about halfway
through is the part for installing wheel
files by that website otherwise you can
start at the beginning now if you're on
Linux or Mac your life is a little
better and what you're going to want to
do is we will be using Python 3 for
pretty much this entire tutorial there
may come a time where you have to use
Python 2 but ideally python 3 so this
will be pip 3 install and you might get
numpy obviously if you don't have pip 3
suit-up get pip 3 or it might be Python
3 pip something like that anyway get it
then you're also going to want the other
thing you can do is apt-get install
python 3
- numpy something like that numpy
matplotlib and then for you
it'll be apt-get install python - open
CV just like that get that and you
should have it
when it all is done you should be able
to it looks like I'm actually in Python
right now you should be able to run
import cb2 and not get any errors also
make sure you can do import matplotlib
and import numpy once you can do all
that you're ready to rumble so let's
talk about some of the things that we're
going to be covering in this tutorial so
first of all let me pull up some images
here so if you look at the top left
there that would be a background
subtraction so it's kind of like a
filter that you can apply and objects
that are moving will come to the
forefront and the objects aren't moving
can be removed entirely so you can use
something like this and then you later
on can revert back to color and have the
original image on the top right here
we've got edge detection which just
basically detects edges of things as the
name might suggest on the bottom left
we've got some feature matching going on
so as you can see actually that pillows
rotate its different angle and all that
and we're still able to make matches and
then on the bottom right we've got a
filter for a very specific range of red
colors and various blurs applied to it
and then finally here this is an example
of face detection eye detection and
Watch detection the idea for these and
this last thing here actually is you
know faces and eyes are relatively easy
to detect people have the code that you
need to do that but we'll even talk
about how you can create your own object
recognition with you know for basically
any object you could ever want so that's
really cool on so that's what we're
going to be talking about this could be
a pretty in-depth series so with that
let's go ahead and hop in so the first
thing that we want to do is we need a
sample image of some kind I'm going to
use a pretty simple image here mine is
just going to be an image of a watch so
pull up that image yet you can use for
this part you can use any image you want
take your own image or just grab one
offline this isn't going to be very
integral for a lot of the tutorial I'm
going to recommend that you use
something unique to yourself so it makes
it a little more interesting but all
throughout you can use my images if you
want so anyways let's go ahead and talk
about loading in an image feed basically
so the first thing that we're going to
want to do is we want to import cb2
import numpy as MP and then import mat
plot lived up pie plot as PLT now the
way the image analysis works and video
analysis works is pretty much identical
so a video as you're probably aware at
least in computer form is measured in
you know frames per second so each frame
is actually a still image so the way
that cv works is you can either analyze
an image which is the identical
thing is a still frame so all the
functions and everything that you're
going to perform an analysis is very
easily interchangeable between video and
image so first we're going to talk about
how to handle an image and how to handle
a video and then most of this tutorial
series will actually be done with video
but if you don't have like a webcam or
something or a sample video to use then
you can always just use an image so the
first thing we're going to do is we're
going to go ahead and define an image
every one si that's just CV to M read
which is just image read and then here
you specify the image - watch jpg use
whatever you want and then you have the
sort of like a filter that you want to
apply to it so cb2 got em read
underscore grayscale if you don't
specify anything it'll read in a it will
read it in as a colored image but it
removes the Alpha Channel if you're not
familiar with alpha it's a degree of
opaqueness basically the opposite of
transparency so with image analysis we
generally convert to grayscale because
grayscale is much further simplified
okay so a grayscale image is a lot
easier to perform analysis on than a
full color image and then just imagine a
full color plus an alpha channel so full
color has basically three colors right
RGB or in the case of CV - it's actually
BG R and then if you add alpha that's BG
R a so now you've got four major colors
that you're dealing with so we usually
convert to grayscale and just kick out
alpha so then we're really dealing with
one color so it's a lot more it's a lot
easier it's a lot faster now you can do
image analysis and video analysis in
full color it's going to take a lot more
processing so anyway we were reading to
grayscale just as a note basically the
other options you have is M read whoops
M read underscore color and then you've
also got em read underscore unchanged
you can read in those also you can read
them in as numbers so sometimes you'll
see them in his numbers so color will
corresponds to the number
and try to think of the other ones
grayscale is zero so by default you'll a
lot of times see people put the image
name and then a zero and you're like
what's that zero that just corresponds
to image grayscale and then this one I
shouldn t use dashes I suppose but this
one equals negative one so if you don't
want it to be changed you can use a
negative one okay so that's what's
reading in the image now we can we can
show the image in a lot of ways we can
show it in for example I'll show in
matplotlib first and then we'll show in
a later tutorial how to just do regular
showing by a CV showing in matplotlib is
obviously kind of useful because you can
actually plot on the image with
matplotlib you can also have like
multiple figures and stuff like that so
again with matplotlib if you're not too
familiar with it it's not going to be
necessary to know map what live for the
series we're actually not going to use
it very much but there is a map plot Lib
tutorial series let's head over there
real quick come to start learning data
analysis data visualization major
matplotlib series so keep that in mind
if you want to learn more about it
otherwise carry on so what we can do
actually is I'll go ahead and show you
guys in CV actually so CV - I'll show
you map a Lib - but CV - in show and
then you title the window whatever you
want we'll tile it image and then you
show the image okay then we're going to
just see v2 dot weight key 0 basically
this just waits for any key to be
pressed and then once a key is pressed C
v2 dot dish boy all windows we pull that
up we got a problem
what did I do I've got a random Coulter
let's try again and here is our image
simple enough it's called image and all
that we can move it about we can close
like that and that's ok but the other
thing that we can do is press a key and
it also closes later on we'll use like a
q4 quit or an escape for quit something
like that
so that's how you can show the image
with CV now with matplotlib you can also
very easily show the image so for
example we can do we'll move this code
also just comment it out and what we can
do is PL TM show and we can show the
image we'll say the C map equals gray
you can show color but mat plot let's
see C OpenCV does BG our mat pot lived
as RGB so when you feed through
something that is B gr and it's treated
as RGB obviously the colors are a little
wrong so keep that in mind
now enter Palais Shin will call this by
cubic by cubic if we can spell and then
we can go ahead really we can get away
or we should be able to get away with
PLT show real quick let's make sure
everything's working up to this point
sure enough there's your watch these
would be your you know your basically
your coordinates so up here is zero zero
and then down here you know so you can
get all your pixel values and you can
you can actually plot things so for
example PLT dot plot and let's just plot
a couple really simple let's do 50 100
and then we'll do 80 100 and let's color
that cyan give it a line width of 5 go
ahead and show that one now and there
you have it we've got a nice line drawn
on there because Oh Matt plot live
you're such a fool anyway because it
wanted to show it's got like automatic
orientation I suppose of the chart so it
shows everything you want to see kind of
move our image but anyway get the idea
you can actually plot directly on there
which is pretty cool and then later on
you can actually plot you know various
scales and stuff like that well I'll
show you some some things and
reasons why you might use matplotlib but
for the most part we'll actually be
using em show even on videos use em show
finally if you do want to save an image
you can use let's go ahead and comment
that out you can use CV to M right and
we can save it as you know great watch
or whatever in the file something like
that and then you know so you can pull
up your image look at it cool awesome we
escape and the image is now saved in our
directory so as you can see that was
pretty easy
in the next tutorial we'll be talking
about video feeds how to load in a video
either by a webcam or by a natural video
file that you might have so anyways if
you have questions comments concerns up
to this point there's kind of a lot
covered here especially in the
installation process but I'll be happy
to help you if you're having any trouble
otherwise as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support subscriptions
and it's till next time